in the last video we did some examples
where we had one digit repeating on and
on forever and we were able to convert
those into fractions in this video we
want to tackle something a little bit
more interesting which is multiple
digits repeating on and on forever so
let's say I had zero point zero point
three six repeating which is the same
thing as zero point since the bars over
the 3 and the 6 both of those repeat 3 6
3 6 3 6 and it just keeps going on and
on and on like that forever now the key
to doing this type of problem is instead
of multiplying so like we did in the
last video we said this is equal to X
instead of just multiplying it by 10 10
would only shift it 1 over we want to
shift it over enough so that we can kind
of so that the the when we line them up
the decimal parts will still line up
with each other and to do that we want
to actually shift the decimal space two
to the right and if we to shift it two
to the right we have to multiply by a
hundred or ten to the second power so
100 X 100 X is going to be equal to what
we're shifting this two to the right one
two so 100x is going to be equal to is
going to be equal to the decimal is
going to be there now so it's going to
be thirty six point three six three six
three six on and on and on forever and
then let me rewrite X over here we're
going to subtract that from the hundred
X X is equal to zero point three six
three six three six repeating on and on
forever and notice when we multiply it
by 100 X the 3s and the six is still
line up with each other when we line the
decimals and you want to make sure you
get the decimals lined up appropriately
and the reason why this is valuable is
now that when we subtract X from 100x
this the repeating parts will cancel out
so let's subtract let us subtract these
two things so on the left hand side we
have 100 X minus X so that gives us 99 X
and then we get on the right hand side
this part cancels out with that part
we're just left with 36 we're just left
with 36 we can divide both sides by 99
and we are left with we are left with X
is equal to 36
over 99 and both the numerator and the
denominator is divisible by nine so we
can reduce this we divide the numerator
by nine we get for the denominator by
nine we get 11
so 0.36 three six three six forever and
forever repeating is four 11s now let's
do another interesting one let's say I
have and I'll just set it equal to X
well let's say we had the number let's
say we have the number zero point seven
one four and the one four is repeating
and so this is the same thing so notice
the seven one four isn't going to repeat
just the one four is going to repeat so
this is zero point seven one four one
four one four on and on and on and on so
let's set this equal to X now you might
be tempted to multiply this by a
thousand X to get the decimal all the
way clear of one seven one four so get
the decimal all the way clear of seven
one four but you actually don't want to
do that you want to shift it just enough
so that you can so that the repeating
pattern can be right under itself when
you when you do the subtraction so again
in this situation even though we have
three numbers behind the decimal point
because only two of them are repeating
we only want to multiply by 10 to the
second power
so once again you want to multiply by
100 so you get 100 X is equal to we're
moving the decimal two to the right one
two so it's going to be seventy one
point four one four one on and on and on
and on so it's going to be seventy one
point four one four one four one four
and on and on and on and then let me
rewrite X right below this we have X is
equal to zero point seven one four one
four one four and notice now the 1/4 is
1/4 1/4 so they're lined up right below
each other so it's going to work out
when we subtract so let's subtract these
things 100 X minus X is 99 X and this is
going to be equal to these 1 4 1 4 s are
going to cancel with those 1/4 1/4 s and
we have 71 point 4 minus point 7 we can
do this in our head or
borrow if you like this could be a 14
this is a zero so you have 0.4 14 minus
7 is 7 and then 70 minus 0 so you have
99 X is equal to 70 point 7 and then we
can divide both sides by 99 you can see
also something strange is happening
because we still have a decimal but we
can fix that up at the end so let's
divide both sides by 99 let's divide
both sides by 99 you get X is equal to
70 point 7 over 99 now obviously we
haven't converted this into a pure
fraction yet we still have a decimal in
the numerator but that's pretty easy to
fix you just have to multiply the
numerator and the denominator by 10 to
get rid of this decimal so let's
multiply the numerator by 10 and the
denominator by 10 and so we get seven
hundred and seven seven hundred and
seven over over nine hundred and ninety
let's do one more example over here so
let's say let's say we had something
like 1 let me write it this way three
point two five seven repeating and we
want to convert this into a fraction so
once again we set this equal to X and
notice this is going to be three point
two five seven two five seven two five
seven the to five seven is going to
repeat on and on and on
since we have three digits are repeating
we want to multiply this we want to
think about a thousand X 10 to the third
power times X so and that'll let us
shift it just right so that the
repeating parts can cancel out so we can
get so 1000x1000 x is going to be equal
to what we're going to shift the decimal
three to the right one two three so it's
going to be three thousand two hundred
and fifty-seven point and then the two
five seven keeps repeating two five
seven two five seven two five seven
keeps going on and on and on forever and
then we're going to subtract X from that
so here's X X is equal to three you want
to make sure you have your decimals
lined up it's three point two five seven
two five seven two five seven dot-dot
keeps going on forever notice when we
multiplied it by a thousand it allowed
us to line up the two fives
so that when we subtract the repeating
part cancels out so let's do that
subtraction on the left-hand side a
thousand of something minus 1 of that
something you're left with 999 of that
something is equal to this part is going
to cancel out with that part it's going
to be equal to let's see 7 minus 3 is 4
and then you have this the 5 the 2 and
the 3 so you get 999 X is equal to three
thousand two hundred and fifty four and
then you can divide the numerator or
divide both sides of this by 999 both
sides by 999 and you are left with X is
equal to three thousand two hundred and
fifty-four over 999 and so obviously
this is an improper fraction the
numerator is larger than the denominator
you could convert this to a proper
fraction if you like one way you could
have just tried to figure out what the
the to the point two five seven
repeating forever is equal to and just
have three being the whole number part
of a mixed fraction or you can just
divide 999 into 3254 actually we could
do that pretty straightforwardly it goes
into it three times and the remainder
well let me do it let me do it so let me
just do it just to go through the
motions so nine nine nine goes into 3254
it'll go into it three times and we know
that because this is originally three
point two five seven so we're just going
to find the remainder so 3 times 9 is 27
3 times 9 is 27 but we have to add the
two so it's 29 3 times 9 is 27 we have a
2 so it's 29 and so we are left with if
we subtract if we regroup or borrow or
however we want to call it this could be
a 14 and then this could be a 4 let me
do this in a new color this would be a 4
and then the 4 is still smaller than
this 9 so we need to regroup again so
then this could be a 14 and then this
could be a 1 but this is smaller than
this 9 right over here so we regroup
again this would be an 11 and then this
is a 2 14 minus 7 is 7 14 minus 9 is 5
11 minus 9
is too so we are left with we are left
with did I do that right yep so this is
going to be equal to three and 257 over
nine nine nine and we're done